um so thank you so much for the
introduction my name is Christiana
skullman and I'm the director of us
email change.org um and thank you so
much for attending this presentation I'm
really excited to be here I've been with
change.org for a little over two years
now and I've been able to watch the
exponential growth that's happened on
our platform and just the millions of
people who come to our site to start
petitions to make change in their lives
are in the world and it's been an
inspiring ride and I'm happy to share
some of those stories with you guys
today so um change or as you just got a
little bit of briefing on has grown
quite large since it was founded in 2007
we have over 1.2 million visitors daily
and um currently are sitting at around
77 78 million users globally um and I'm
hoping that we're going to reach up to
100 million users by the end of the year
which will be a fun celebration um so
our mission um is to empower anyone
anywhere to create the change in the
world that they hope to see um we are
currently the world's largest petition
platform there are plenty of other
places you can go on the internet to
start petitions but we are the one that
Garners the most users and the most
individual visits um and sometimes this
change can be as small as asking a local
town to put in a stop sign on a sidewalk
um or to put in a stoplight um at a busy
intersection or it can be as big as
dozens of countries around the world
starting petitions asking their head of
state or the Nobel committee to nominate
and um Award malalo with the Nobel Peace
Prize um I was actually really excited
to include this slide because I'm not
sure if folks listened to the news or
NPR this morning but this is actually a
victory this petition won as of today um
and it was started by several different
people in many different countries in
fact I think there were over 16
petitions specifically calling for
either like I said their heads of state
in the specific country to support
Malala um receiving the Nobel Peace
Prize um or calling on the Nobel
committee to nominate her um so this is
pretty incredible and combined total
there were almost a million people
people worldwide who signed petitions
calling for this
change so change Network's Mission as I
mentioned in the beginning is to create
a world where no one is powerless um
this is a picture of Jen Tyrell who was
a boy scouts den leader which is
essentially like the leader of a troop
for Boy Scouts um and she was kicked out
and asked to resign because she's gay
and when she when that happened to her
she actually turned to change. organ and
started a petition sharing her story
with users explaining that she felt like
she'd been discriminated against and she
just wanted to be a part of her son's
life and didn't see why it was fair or
why it was okay that she was being asked
to leave and not participate um in this
activity with her family um simply
because of her
orientation and her petition her
individual petition got over 300,000
signatures at the time of this delivery
where the picture is from it had about
300,000 but I think it's up to 600,000
now and it really sparked an incredible
movement in the United States um the Boy
Scouts is I think folks may be familiar
with is one of the sort of it's an I
would consider to be an Antiquated
institution it's not one that is likely
to be receptive to outside influence um
they are very publicly aligned with
conservative and religious values and
have public opinions on homosexuality
and so they're not a likely candidate to
say yes you're right we're
discriminating against you and we're
going to change um but her story brought
forth many many other stories of people
who were involved in the Boy Scouts um
specifically one kid who was 18 years
old his name was Ryan Anderson and he
was denied his Eagle Scout specifically
because he was gay and his mother after
hearing about Jennifer Tyrell started a
petition um specifically calling on the
Boy Scouts to award her son his Eagle
Award and it got over a million
signatures he got incredible media from
this attention um it sparked whole
movement of other Scouts stepping
forward and identifying as being gay and
being kicked out of their troops for the
same reason um and because of that um
this like a really incredibly
coordinated campaign over eight months
later the Boy Scouts announced in like a
very historic decision that they were no
longer going to discriminate against gay
Scouts and that they were going to allow
them to participate in the Boy Scouts of
America organization um which is pretty
incredible um unfortunately for Jen
though she is still waiting for them to
allow gay parents um many people think
that it's just a matter of time um but
she is still not allowed to participate
in the Boy Scouts with her son um but
I'm telling her story because this is a
really important example of how one
person's story on and using the our
platform on change.org has helped spark
a national movement and made some really
significant change in a organization
that was expected to sort of be that was
considered sort of
unchangeable um this is a picture of
Matt Zeller and he is a US Army veteran
who served in Iraq and Afghanistan and
he worked really closely with the man
who's pictured to his left whose name is
um Janice shinari who was his
interpreter while he was in Afghanistan
and um I've seen interviews of Matt and
he just has so much emotion and deep
connection to Janice and says that
without him and his help um as a
interpreter in Afghanistan that he would
have died and that many their their
mission would have been unsuccessful and
their deployment would have been a lot
more dangerous than it was um but
unfortunately for interpreters who are
allied with American troops um in
different countries they're often
considered enemies of the state or
combatants of the um sorry enemies of
the um oppositional forces and so when
this specific deployment left and um
Janice was no longer associated with the
United States military he was considered
an enemy of the Taliban and when Matt
came back to the United States Janice
contacted him and said I'm fearing for
my life I applied for United States visa
and I've been to the Embassy in cabul
several times and I don't think my Visa
application is going to go anywhere and
I don't think that anyone is hearing me
and I'm going to die like I'm receiving
death threats I cannot leave my house
the Taliban is going to kill me they're
going to kill other interpreters as well
it's very dangerous for people to be
interpreters associated with the United
States troops so Matt turned to
change.org and started a petition
specifically asking for the embassy to
FastTrack his visa and he got over
113,000 signatures he got a lot of media
attention once his petition started
gaining Steam and this also brought
forth an entire like crop of other
stories and petitions from other
veterans or active service members who
had also worked with interpreters in
other countries who um who were also
facing similar challenges to Janice um
in their home countries and Janice's
Visa ended up being approved which is
absolutely incredible and they had a
very tearful and emotional reuniting um
in DC and several other interpreters who
were also applying for visas got those
approved as well simply because they
heard about the single person match who
started a petition on change.org and was
able to make a really significant impact
in the life of somebody who helped him
quite a
bit so you might be asking yourself and
we started to delve into this a little
bit in um a conversation I had with a
few of you right before the presentation
why petitions um and I am here to argue
and to tell you that's because they work
um so change.org was founded in 2007 and
has since gained over 78 million users
worldwide as I mention mentioned um and
we're growing every single month in the
US every day people have taken action
over 450 million times um by signing
petitions which has resulted in over
10,000 victories um worldwide change R
users have won petitions in 121
countries and 31 million users globally
have signed a winning petition which is
a lot of winning and a lot of Victories
but you might also be asking yourself
well I don't imagine that I could just
go start a petition and it would win
automatically how does all this winning
happen and and that's where I come in so
I mentioned earlier that I am the
director of us email and um actually
just to get a quick show of hands in
this room who here receives email from
change.org a couple folks great um well
I would love to talk to you after this
presentation um if you'd be willing to
answer some of my questions about your
experience as an email receiver um but
we do send a lot of email and it's
because it escalates petitions so that
people can get the attention of the
decision maker or the person being
targeted in a given petition
um not every campaign needs a lot of
signatures in order to win but any
amount of signatures helps put pressure
on the decisionmaker of the
petition so as I mentioned um I work on
the email team and my team is comprised
of actually a very small amount of
people for the amount of users that we
manage in the United States we have one
Storyteller so somebody who works
directly with people who start petitions
to help craft their stories and make
them as compelling as possible so that
they're translatable over email and they
can bwell um one local and Niche email
campaigner who works with smaller more
localized issues they may not have
National or broad appeal um and one
production specialist and we manage a
list of over 23 million in the US and
also assist our Global teams so our
mission as a team is to deliver users
petitions that they will connect with
and care about um Jennifer Tyrell didn't
know that she was tapping into a broader
experience of discrimination when she
started her petition or brought her
Narrative of other people who felt like
they had been wronged by the boy of
America um and wasn't sure that anyone
was really going to care and my team was
able to rigorously test her story in
different content formats um to various
segments to find the most engaged and
targeted and most likely to respond
audience of our list um and this boost
of support from the United States um
from change aor users in the United
States is what really gave her petition
the notoriety that it needed for her to
start getting media attention um and the
campaign just really took off from there
so like I said we're a small small team
and we try to serve as many inspiring
stories as possible like Jens um and
Matts to the right people um in 2014 we
sent over 500 in this year we've sent
over 550 million emails Alone um and
we're not even at the end of the year
yet which is making me sweat a little
bit um but we do it by putting the
petition starter story first and
foremost um in every single email and it
wasn't always as easy as it has been now
um and we sometimes had to make
targeting sacrifices to get there and
that um brings me to getting to sort of
the heart of this presentation and this
discussion so in the beginning um we
grouped petitions by issue area and
called them causes and we had 12
specific ones um that we use to
primarily Target our audiences um and
they included causes like animals uh
criminal justice economic Justice
education food gay rights women's rights
immigration um we had a human
trafficking cause it was quite small um
but this was our most granular way of
testing petitions um but as you can
imagine it had some really serious
drawbacks so some of these causes were
full of much more active users like
human trafficking for example um and it
really biased our test results whereas
some of them were much more large and um
were just more diluted and so they
almost never met the testing benchmarks
that they needed to in order to go
widely which created a system in which
our most active users were possibly
getting hit over the head with email and
were being punished maybe for being
interested in change up organ interested
in helping other people's lives and
sending petitions which is certainly not
a delightful user experience for anyone
and not one that we would want to
recreate and also one in which somebody
who might be in a less active cause is
not meeting the testing requirements in
order to go widely and may not be
receiving any sort of email whatsoever
and maybe sign one petition on
change.org and then never heard from us
again so you can imagine how a petition
like Matt Zellers might not really fit
neatly into one of these broad cause
affiliations which actually happened
quite often and sometimes we would test
to multiple causes um and sometimes we
just had to make sacrifices like sending
to a full audience even if the test was
low performing because the petition
needed to meet a certain number of
signatures in order for it to get
attention in media in order for the
petition to escalate and the campaign to
really take off and for people like
Jennifer Tyrell to end up winning their
campaigns so my team and I actually
manually targeted campaign emails based
largely on petition or cause affiliation
and other segmenting capabilities of our
CRM um like sending to designers of
related petitions and this created a
system in which each person on my team
really became like a specialist in that
specific cause audience so this actually
worked pretty well for about a year and
a half um until it really didn't um so
this is a petition that was started by a
young woman named Alexandra and she is a
survivor of sexual assault while she was
at Yale um and the school reviews to
refused to investigate her
assault so before we got machine
learning targeting capabilities we had a
really tough time with this campaign um
as I mentioned earlier and as I shared
with a with you all we really pride
ourselves on putting the petition
starter story front and center and all
the work that we do um that's just a
really strong way we found of being able
to connect individuals with different
issues that they may not connected with
before um but we found that putting a
story that may that had such disturbing
content as Alexandra's was actually not
testing very well to our list even
though it was was very compelling and a
very strong campaign and it had a very
smart Target and it fit all the other
criteria for being a good petition we
just could not find an audience that was
responding well and that was converting
well enough for us to justify sending
widely but we knew that this campaign
was important to work on and so we ended
up we ended up sending to a couple cause
audiences um at around 500,000
recipients and had like a 3 to 4% action
rate and we're generally sort of feeling
unsatisfied because we knew that this
this campaign had a huge potential to
make a really big impact on the
conversation around sexual assault and
title n in this country but thankfully
um this is around the same time that our
data scientists and data Engineers were
developing um machine learning targeting
capabilities for us and with machine
learning we found that more than a
million we found more than a million
recipients at a 12 to 16% conversion um
and the campaign did well beyond
anything that we could have done with
our previous tools um this allowed us to
empower over 175,000 people to take
action on this issue and to connect with
Alexander directly and just show her
that across the country that people
really stood with her on this issue um
the other thing that I want to say here
is that um much like Jen and Matt
Zeller's stories this young woman's
petition really sparked um just sort of
a tidal wave of really similar stories
and petitions on change.org about other
individuals who had experienced sexual
assault on their campus and um had also
received lackluster or deniability from
their school um Administration and we're
also looking to hold them accountable
and this PE petition actually went on to
be a victory um several months ago when
the Obama Administration announced a
task force for tital and sexual assault
specifically um which was pretty
incredible and since then Alexander has
actually started an organization um to
connect with other young women such as
herself um and was just recently
featured in The New York Times for her
work which is really incredible and
inspiring um here's another example um
albeit a little bit heavy and sad of a
topic
um but this is a petition that the
campaigns that my team nicknamed save
Michaela and it was started by her
husband and this woman who um is
actually about my age was diagnosed with
kidney cancer um shortly after they were
married and they found that none of the
treatments um none of the routine
treatments and recommendations were
working but there was an experimental
drug that was proving in early stages to
be doing quite well and her and her
husband were interested in trying it but
the pharmaceutical company that owned
the rights to this drug were not
interested in allowing um um anyone
outside of the experimental phase to try
it or to use it and so they ended up
starting a petition asking this company
to allow them to do so and um it was
just like such a powerful story but
knowing with the tools that we had
previously around cause targeting there
would not have been a clear way to send
this to people um that would have
resulted in us getting it into the right
people's inboxes so we had a health
cause I don't know if you saw that when
that slide was up there we had a health
cause um and could have easily sent it
to those people but it was a pretty
small audience um it probably wouldn't
have performed very well but this is
also missing out on just like a huge
amount of us users who may have been
really interested in this story and
helping Michaela get this medication and
get this treatment um so what caused
targeting really Illustrated to us is
that it just lacked the Nuance in
individual's interests and opinions
necessary to really scale and facilitate
the support that we needed in order to
have the kind of permeation and reach um
for change .org in the United States so
with machine learning um we sent this to
over 5 million users total with high
performing sends going to over 250,000
sorry 215,000 converting at around 16%
which is pretty incredible um and like I
said without machine learning this
probably would have gone to like a
maximum two million people um at an
audience of like or at a conversion of
like four to 5% which is definitely not
ideal so manual targeting as I just sort
of started to get into just really fails
to scale um it doesn't scale cognitively
so how do we order segments when there's
overlap of conflicting needs like when
there's a really high convergence or
really high conversion versus a certain
campaign needing a certain amount of
signatures in order to get media
attention um it doesn't also scale on
Personnel so as I mentioned my teammates
ended up becoming sort of well-versed
experts in these individual issue areas
but we're just individuals and there
were only four of us and there's only so
much that we could know about any sort
of given cause or audience in that cause
grouping um they don't scale into Mass
customization so we can't take risk with
Niche campaigns we have users on the
site who will care about a certain cause
so so so much um but we cannot reach
them on mass and we cannot torture our
broader user base with these like really
small specific Niche issues but our team
often had to sacrifices across the list
for campaigns with Broad and Urgent
appeal um and often just included people
who had really Niche specific issues
even though they made have were not
necessarily interested in the broader
issues and a specific example here is
that we have actually like a quite
active Gaming Community on change.org of
people who start petitions around
specific video games um and they tend to
not really be interested in anything
else and that's absolutely fine and so
just being able to have the capabilities
to find those people who are interested
in specific gaming petitions and gaming
issues and exclude them from the rest of
our work it also doesn't scale
culturally oops sorry about that wrong
way um and what matters in any given
culture even broadly is profoundly
diverse and with distinct top level
concerns and difference in meaning even
with ostensively the same concerns um um
so even within the us giving people a
voice meant moving on from being yet
another Progressive advocacy
organization to a neutral platform for
making change so now we have both Pro
and anti-gun constituencies that we can
serve because of this targeting whereas
before it would have been really hard to
find and Target those people without
running the risk of burning our users
and getting a lot of unsubscribed from
people who are potentially very very
proun um or anti-gun um and then lastly
it just doesn't scale with data size and
load so the MySQL reporting slave that
was used for the SQL selector um was
already falling over and we just
frequently ran into limitations with our
tool and with our platform um even with
nothing even if nothing else had changed
the technical tools were beginning to
fail and we knew that it was only a
matter of time until the the system just
fell over on itself so we we were forced
to move on um the last thing that I want
to say before I hand it over to you
Melanie is that um I just want to talk
about Jennifer Tyrell again sorry let me
go back um
yeah
yep
okay um so like I said we did not have
machine learning targeting capabilities
at the time that Jennifer Tyrell started
her petition we did have a gay rights
cause group that we were able to send
widely to um and I just I just like to
think that even though we were able to
put her petition and her story in front
of change network users who were
genuinely interested in cared very
deeply about it the reason why so many
Boy Scouts petitions following hers were
so successful is because we had this
smarter targeting algorithm that allowed
us to send it to people who are really
like cared deeply about this and I just
Jen is still today fighting for the
right to be able to be a gay mother and
be involved in her boy scouts troops and
I think that will happen for her one day
um but I just think that it's
unfortunate that at the time we just
didn't have the scalability and the
diversity in Tools in order to really
meet her um her
needs well hand over you so uh I'm going
to take on the portion around data
science and to explain to you guys sort
of what the actual uh algorithm was that
we use to help us provide better
targeting uh and my name is Melanie War
I'm a data scientist at change.org um so
let's talk about data science all right
uh how many of you guys have actually
used machine learning
algorithms okay so there's a good good
number of you which I would expect in
this class from um what I heard was the
audience uh I'll try to be brief on this
just to make sure we're all on the same
page machine learning because it does
get a lot of t uh it gets talked about a
lot nowadays is really about a set of
algorithms or um algorithms that you can
use to build out models for prediction
and or pattern matching and you see
machine learning in all kinds of things
nowadays I mean you could use it to
predict uh or try to predict how stocks
are going to perform or how the weather
is going to be or you could use it for
facial recognition
or um uh voice recognition uh machine
learning is definitely being used in a
number of different ways to do s some
type of problem solving especially when
it gets into some type of software space
uh the simplest form of machine learning
or the the go-to for a lot of people is
going to be linear regression and I'm
sure most of us know yal MX plus b is
the equation of on line so if you have a
data set um especially something with a
scatter plot and you want to try predict
the next value that you're going to get
around this data you'll basically build
a line and you'll find the most optimal
slope and intercept and then the next
time you get any kind of independent
variable for your X you'll be able to
come back and say based on this data set
that we've built the model off of we
predict this is what Y is and really uh
a lot of these machine learning
algorithms they're much more complex but
they're taking in a lot of independ
independent variables to predict some
type of dependent uh variable result so
what we decided to do because what we
were really trying to um optimize for
was our sign descend rate we wanted to
make sure that based on the number of
emails we were sending we could get good
signature rates and it's hard you know
it's not necessarily I'm sure you all
get a lot of emails I do too where
you're just like I'm I'm ignoring those
emails but we wanted to see if we could
find better ways to Target the audience
we are going to go after to that would
be more interested in these emails and
and in these campaigns so we used uh we
decided because of that goal that we
were going to go with some
classification algorithms and the first
thing we want to look at is you know
what are we going to use as our
independent variables what are going to
be our features to help us build our
model um specifically when you're
talking about the problem our user is
our Target we want to predict our users
Behavior we want to predict will the
user sign so we want to build out a
feature set around those users and
specific specifically we want to think
about okay what are their demographics
you know where do they live um what
what's their gender if this information
was something they provided to us we
also want to leverage features like
their Affinity you know how many
petitions have they signed that are
related to a certain type of topic a
certain type of cause and their um
activity you know how often have they
logged into our site how often have they
opened the emails that have been sent to
them so those are types of uh features
that we would use to build out a feature
around our user base and we would use
that to feed into the models and see if
we could do some level of better
prediction on how they would per how
they would interact with the emails so
and then we also used like I said we
were going after classification
algorithms um and specifically we looked
at logistic regression support Vector
models and random Forest uh these are
typically pretty uh solid performing
classification algorithms especially for
the case that we were trying to uh
address so what we found was logistic
regression is actually a pretty typical
model it's uh pretty simple to go after
when you're trying to do some type of
classification um it's great for you
know basically taking linear regression
and uh adjusting it so you do you're
estimating the probability of a
classification off of linear regression
guessing many of you might already know
this um but support Vector U models how
many of you guys actually know what a
support Vector model
is okay I got some hands all right so at
the so with with logistic regression
you're using it usually when you have
input variables you're X variable in the
model which is going to be for us uh I
think we had about 500 features at the
end of the day um your input variables
may you may not believe as strongly in
what they can predict and how they can
classify so that's why you would use
logistic regression uh whereas or that's
a case for why you would use logistic
regression whereas with svm the those
input variables could actually be very
strong indicators and when you start to
get so many cuz I just mentioned 500
imagine trying to do 500 Dimensions you
know you can think about two dimensions
three dimensions but when you start to
talk about such extreme Dimensions there
may be a very clear place to divide that
and support Vector model allows you to
model all those dimensions and then
literally draw a line or what we like to
say is a hyperplane through to help
Define and divide and say this group of
people will sign a petition for
Alexandra these won't so that's how you
would use a support Vector model and
then svdd is actually a very variation
off of support Vector model and really
it's because data might group into a
nice circular kind of pattern and allow
you to actually pick a specific point
within the data and use a radius to help
you define a classification specifically
around that data um for us we found that
our data didn't really group we tried
but our data didn't really come together
in in a circular fashion so SVD had uh
svdd sounds anyway um it had a it had
very low performance for us uh but what
we did you know we did get some fairly
decent scores for performance with uh
linear with logistic regression and with
the svm the reality is at the end of the
day um there you have to binarize your
data our data happened to be so it it
requires a lot of extra work in terms of
featurization um our data also that we
were using to build these models was
very unbalanced uh we're talking about
maybe about 2% that's positive and with
that you could predict 100% of the time
that people will not sign and you'd be
98% correct um but for us we knew we
wanted to be able to actually send
emails so we needed to be able to get a
model that would give us a prediction um
and allow us to hopefully as clearly as
possible and cleanly as possible predict
uh that we are going to get some
signatures we had some techniques like
oversampling and so forth that we were
able to use to help help us improve our
performance on these different
algorithms um but the reality was you
know we found that we wanted to go with
a random forest and I'll explain why as
I go
into talking about decision tree so does
everybody here know what a decision tree
is yeah I figure does everybody has
anybody here used a random
Forest okay so decision trees right um
you've got a lot of you could have a lot
of different features a lot of questions
you can create a tree a diagram of those
questions if you ask this question and
you say yes or no or you're you say what
state are you from and you mention which
state it'll take you down one branch
versus another um in this case this
example that I have up here let's say
you're sick and you go to a doctor and
that doctor has a specialization in
malaria so they'll ask you a specific
set of questions and then they'll come
back and say okay you have malaria and
that's great because you know that's not
scary at all and you might think well
maybe I should go and get a second
opinion and so you go to a second doctor
and that doctor is a generalist and
they're going to ask you maybe some of
the same questions that the doctor the
first doctor asked you um but maybe in a
different order and probably some other
questions that the first doctor didn't
ask you and come back and say you got
the flu so okay you've got two different
opinions going on here and you're
thinking which one do I trust now if you
had all the time and the money in the
world maybe you would go talk to 100
doctors and you'd get opinions from all
those doctors and when it boiled down to
it each one gives you some type of
diagnosis well what does that diagnosis
mean to you if you add it all up and you
find that the most common diagnosis
let's say um 10 out of a 100 doctors
said you have the flu and there was
nothing that was more common than that I
think you can have pretty solid
confidence that you have the flu and not
malaria and what the beauty is of having
all of those doctors give you giving you
a diagnosis is that when one of them
says you have Mal malaria uh and you you
have let's say several others that give
you a different diagnosis but nobody
else that gives you the same at that
that same diagnosis they sort of cancel
each other out it's a voting mechanism
so imagine multiple decision trees
that's what you get as a r random Forest
so for us um we decided to go with
random forest and part of the reason why
is because we could have picked out
those 10 doctors and figured out what
were the questions they asked and we
could dive more in into more detail
about what were the decisions what were
the actual features that they use to get
to that label um so it's not really a
black box it's much easier to dive into
and understand what features went into
it uh we don't have to do cross
validation with logistic regression and
svm we actually have to do cross
validation uh to be able to really
verify our models and make sure that
they don't overfit um we're able to it
it also helps us perform feature
selection we can throw as much features
as we want into the models and very and
the random force will build out
variations uh of those kinds of features
that we want to try out to see which
ones will be the most uh predictive so
with the random
Forest what we did was uh we still email
a sample set not as many but we still
need to email a sample set of users for
each campaign and we decided to to try
this out we did an initial like 10
campaigns we emailed the sample set got
back responses within 24 hours and use
that result to help us actually build
out our random Force model um from
there we were able to graph you know
based on all the users that we have uh
that we could potentially
email whether what their conversion rate
is going to be what their signed to send
rate is going to be and we allowed each
campaigner or we allowed the campaigners
basically to determine what would be the
threshold in terms of how those users
were grafted for each campaign to to
sort of cut off and say well we only
want to for this one campaign let's say
Alexander's campaign we only want to
pick the uh the users who are going to
convert at least 10% and that segment of
users we will then use to determine are
we going to send this email to them or
not and we did that for every single
campaign and every single user so
imagine having features for each user
running all those features for through a
random Force for each campaign to come
back with a conversion rate and then we
use the thres we use the threshold to
cut off for each group of users which
ones for that campaign will actually
sign up will actually be ones we target
so now you've got a campaign and you
said okay these are the groups of users
for this campaign we may email and we
now have if we flip that each user for
each user which campaigns they may
actually be ones we could Target we then
go through and we filter out which ones
have they already seen and then we sort
and say for user a this is the highest
conversion rate so this campaign cign
Alexander's campaign is the one we're
going to send to them because they have
the highest conversion rate for that
user and we do that for every single
user based on all the campaigns that
we've compared them with and then once
we've picked the best campaign per user
the C the the emails are sent and from
there I think the main thing I wanted to
to land on in terms of the machine
learning element is that when we did our
analysis we found that the behavioral
data trumps uh the demographic data that
we typically have so we found that based
on digging into the random Force models
we built uh that behavioral data was
actually outperforming our um
demographic data in terms of being
having predicted power uh we also found
that the algorithm performance uh is not
necessarily the main criteria logistic
regression uh svms and random Force were
all performing within a 5 to 10% uh
accuracy uh the reality for us was
having that Clarity in the random Forest
having that understanding of what
features were defining the actual user
base that we should Target uh the fact
that random Force are really good with
uh features whatever types of features
you throw into it because you don't have
to binarize all your features like let's
say you want to say the states a state
is your um feature or states are your
feature you would have to make each
state a feature set and then say yes or
no on whether that user was in that
feature whereas within a random Forest a
tree could literally have one node that
says State and then 50 branches off of
it um so basically you it's great with
throwing a number of different mixed
types of data into it and allowing you
to um not worry about it being overfit
um because it'll account for many
different types of cases so now that
I've explained a little bit around the
algorithm that we chose a little bit
about why we chose it I'm going to let
Scott talk to you about how that was
actually
implemented uh so I'm Scott I'm one of
the data Engineers for change.org
um and I'm going to talk to you guys a
little bit about what our actual
architecture for performing a lot of the
computations that Melanie had uh talked
about so uh at a high level this is this
is our architecture um there's kind of
like a couple interesting notes the
first of which is that we rely very
heavily on Amazon web services um and I
think this is kind of an architecture
decision that you'll see very frequently
with smaller companies companies that
don't quite have the same amount of
resources um as as large companies like
Google uh or Amazon and basically what
that allows us to do is to scale uh
horizont and leverage a lot of the uh
incredible techn technology that Amazon
has they probably have more Engineers
writing documentation than we have in
the company as a whole um and so using
AWS allows us to focus on some of the
more interesting content choices um and
the data science um the second thing is
that we use S3 a lot um a lot of the
orange lines that you'll see on the on
the diagram are actually S3 flows so S3
gets written um uh the state gets
written into S3 and then different
pieces will read the state back from S3
and what that allows us to do is each of
the different modules inside of this
doesn't need to worry about State um and
we can just sort of use S3 as the state
uh and that sort of allows us to
simplify the actual design of each
individual module as well as uh iterate
on that and try different experiments
because if they all talk to a consistent
data layer then that's something that we
don't really have to worry about as as
much um and you can kind of see in the
on the diagram there's basically three
main pieces to this there is the
predictive piece which generates um the
actual sorts the users into the best
optimal send there is a data extraction
piece which takes all of our production
data and basically verifies it and
cleans it up um and then the third piece
is generating the feature
Matrix um so the feature Matrix as
Melanie mentioned we have about 500
features on uh each user and what the
feature Matrix does is it boils it down
into uh a sparse Matrix so we used to
have like a 5 point scale whether or not
you fit onto a particular point for a
feature um but we found actually that
that increased the complexity and didn't
give us quite a large enough boost in
the predictive model so we actually
boiled that down all the way to
basically a binary zero or one
um and uh so we generate this particular
feature Matrix uh every other week and
we store that into S3 um this job gets
launched through data pipeline which is
an Amazon Tool uh we run uh an elastic
map reduce to verify the data and at the
end of the at the end of the day then
this data gets stored back onto S3 for
for use when we actually compute the
sends um the extract and verify piece so
it takes in a bunch of different uh data
sources uh the main one for us is MySQL
but we also have a couple other
different external providers um for
instance like if you connect to uh with
Facebook then we can also pull in some
of that data about your your friends or
your behavior on that site um and
basically we take all that data and we
churn on it and we make sure that we're
not missing anything we use some of the
other Amazon tools like uh simple
notification system for logging and uh
verification um and then the final piece
here is our prediction uh prediction
piece so for this one we're really uh
leveraging the simple workflow piece
that Amazon has and what this allows us
to do is really dynamically spin up
nodes to generate the processing uh of
the the random Forest that Melanie
talked about
um and basically once all of the uh
user uh and once we get all the
campaigns that we want to Target on
simple workflow allows us to scale
horizontally and uh instances will be
brought up for every single campaign and
so that uh work can occur in
parallel um and then at that point uh
because of the way that simple workflow
works it's kind of like a little bit of
a state machine and you can Define the
different steps steps that things need
to take and the conditions to move on to
the next state um so at that point we
wait for all the predictions to be
completed and then we can sort of
aggregate them back and generate the
optimum flow uh Optimum send for
different for different people um and
that's sort of the the main difference
that um in our new architecture compared
to the previous one um the old one you
sort of picked people at random from the
their generalized category and so you
could sort of miss out on all the
optimization
um with this particular way because you
have all the information about
predictions for different campaign SS
we're able to eliminate some of that
inefficiency um the final piece that we
kind of have is red shift and red shift
is the the piece that we sort of write
uh back some of the statistics and
archit uh and uh data flows from that
um uh we use red shift uh for a variety
of different things most basically for
offline processing we have a business
intelligence analysts that will run
queries against this um the final thing
actually about the architecture is that
this is basically um an outof band
processing piece so if you look at each
of the individual modules those aren't
really fast enough to be run online um
and so as I mentioned about S3 what this
allows us to do is each of these can
take sort of an arbitrary amount of time
um and we're not sort of blocked on any
of these individual pieces we can kind
of kick off this particular service
they'll run uh and then when they finish
um all that stuff kind of gets
aggregated back and that has been a
really big uh win for us because we just
don't have quite uh enough Engineers to
sort of keep track of every single one
of these um and so sort of keeping that
logging on top has been very helpful for
us
uh so uh the main takeaways I guess from
the presentation that we've pull
together just to mention is that we
through this using random Force and and
doing the ation that we did uh we were
able to increase our sign descend rate
by
30% um you know what we also were able
to to this wasn't any additional cost
necessarily for the campaigns that we
were using um uh the actual algorithm
and the way it's being run is pretty
parallel so we can't actually split it
across multiple machines um it doesn't
take as much it doesn't take any
additional time and if anything is
probably more efficient and effective um
the visibility into the volume of each
campaign um is very valuable to be able
to see you know uh what what kind of
volume are these campaigns receiving and
how are they being signed or how many
are getting signed Now versus uh before
it was really kind of an unknown in
terms of how how well are we doing in
terms of our prediction versus our
actual results uh and then our AWS cloud
services allow small groups to achieve
big impact so um we have three Mo main
code contributors and and Scott was
there anything else you'd want to add to
that no um and then this last piece and
I know Chan we were talking about this a
little bit is just overall it's allowing
us to get um petitions really more
targeted into uh the boxes of those who
are interested into our change.org users
in boxes because we'd rather be putting
petitions in front of them that they
potentially could care about and make
better use of what we're sending to them
than just sending them a bunch of you
know information that's useless so we
see this as hopefully not only impacting
you know our users better but also uh
improving the campaigns and the results
that the campaigns can drive um I know
there's a question and we'll definitely
have questions I got one last thing to
hit on unless Christian was there
anything else she wanted to
add uh so we there's a program it's code
for good um or Engineers for change
actually but if you want a code for good
you should consider potentially uh
applying to Engineers for Change and um
this program in particular is an
internship uh it's specifically
available to Juniors and seniors at
Stanford um is it also available to grad
students yes so um this is something
that's being run by uh or is also in
conjunction with Twitter and Google and
um Yahoo and Netflix and so forth and
and it's really about trying to leverage
data uh to help and and well actually
it's about building sophisticated
Technologies um so helping to kind of
participate in Building Technology that
will help uh other people in some way
shape or form and I'm hopefully hitting
upon the it's and in its exclusive uh
internship for the summer of 2015
there's about 5 to 10 spots that'll be
available in it um but it really is
about a program that's you know helping
to to do some work that specifically is
reaching out to disadvantage groups that
currently don't have as much support
especially when it comes to
technology Ben anything else should hit
on with that no great okay so now
questions I'm going to make chran and
Scott come back up to help with
questions so anybody have questions
right now I have a question on the
features that you guys use so on the
random Force you use features relating
to the user correct so they were on the
user's behavior and what they've been
doing right and then from that you
predicted whether they would sign a
petition right the probability they
would sign a petition right did you guys
ever look at the users petitions they
have signed yes and no sign and how that
would correlate like a like CBF or
filtering right so they we decided to go
with classification algorithms versus a
recommender system or collaborative
filter um just because we were trying to
do predictions and you know frankly I
didn't get a full answer on exactly why
collaborative filter has not been fully
explored but I think that they found I
think it was actually explored and they
just found that the classification
algorithm was doing just as as good if
not better performance as the
collaborative filter but yes that was
something that was considered one other
interesting note about that actually is
um we found that our predictive uh
ability actually went up uh after users
signed five or more petitions so a lot
of the companies actually designed
around trying to get people to engage
more and once we get to that particular
Mark um it becomes a particularly useful
uh indicator
yeah any other
questions I have a question about you
mentioned several of the cases you were
looking at personally and like guiding
it I mean how many of it is uh is it
possible for you to look through and
like how do you
decide right yeah that's a great
question so um there is an entire I will
use the mic um there's an entire staff
of people who are tasked with looking at
the content that comes to our site
organically and evaluating whether or
not it meets a certain threshold of
criteria um and once that is valuated
then it sort of cuts a lot of the
petitions that are sort of silly ones
like Mom I would like a puppy or so and
so please go to prom with me um so on
and so forth and then sort of elevates
the one that ones that have a little bit
more substance and may fall into the
categories of being particularly local
in Niche so like I mentioned the stop
sign in a small town um or having more
broader National residents like um like
Matt Zeller's petition asking for the
visa for his interpreter so have you
ever tried machine learning for that
sure so machine learning specifically is
applied like that's that's the Practical
implication or the practical application
of it is that my team uses the machine
learning tool and inputs those campaigns
and then can set the confidence level at
which we want those campaigns to be
targeted and the predicted conversion on
those and then it generates files of
users for us to then input into our
email tool and then
email anybody
else no okay well thank you thank you
everyone
speaker